[Music]
a very good evening you're watching the
press preview it's our chance to check
out sunday's front pages for the first
time and tonight we'll see what's making
the headlines with the journalist and
author rachel shabby and deputy
political editor at the daily mail john
stevens good evening to you too we'll
speak to you in a moment we'll check out
the front pages first though beginning
with the observer which says northern
ireland has slipped into a political
crisis after sinn fein's triumph in the
assembly election with the dup
vowing to block the formation of a new
power sharing executive at stormont
the sunday telegraph leads with housing
secretary michael gove claiming voters
turned against the conservatives in the
local elections because of the housing
crisis
in a change to royal protocol the duke
and duchess of cambridge are set to be
addressed by their first names while on
duty and not their title that's
according to the sunday mirror just
william the headline
and the sunday people reports ukrainian
hackers have attempted to halt putin's
victory party vodka
and don't forget that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch and listen to us talking about
them and i'm joined tonight by rachel
shabby and john stevens great uh to see
you so let's crack on lots to talk about
um it's been a very busy 48 hours or so
rachel let's start with you in the front
of the observer and this uh
huge news this evening seismic as the
observer says shin fein now the largest
party in uh stormont and victory fueling
debate on the future of the union as the
observer says what do you make of it
i think you're absolutely right it's a
massive story it is a seismic shift um
for northern ireland um champagne
secured 29 of the first preference vote
um it's now got the majority
of seats in the northern ireland and
gets to nominate uh the first minister
which is a huge huge change for a
political system in northern ireland
that is designed to keep returning um
unionist parties but it does seem like i
think sky sky news was crunching the
numbers earlier today which is super
interesting because it looks as though
in terms of vote share chimpane hasn't
actually gone up it's just that
um the unious parties and in particular
the dup has been punished
and non-allied parties um have increased
their share and so this punishment of
the dup presumably is the result of it
backing um first of all brexit which
majority of northern ireland uh rejected
but secondly uh the protocol hugely
unpopular protocol which um essentially
puts border checks between uh northern
ireland and britain and therefore for
union voters unionist voters looks like
driving a wedge between northern ireland
and the rest of the uk so it does look
like
um the dep took a hammering
in this election but as you say it is
huge news for northern ireland the first
time this has happened
um
and its consequences could be just as
big yeah um and you're right when you
say uh about the vote share um
it's absolutely split between the
nationalists and the unionists both on
forty percent um john uh we now have
this situation don't we where two of the
uk devolved nations are led by parties
who want to leave it
yeah so i think you've got the
government have got a double nightmare
on this one
firstly you've got the problems of the
protocol that were there before and the
dep is saying it won't go back into a
power sharing agreement unless the
protocol has been sorted out and now
alongside that you've got the problem of
shin fame coming top and suggestions
that this could eventually
lead to a referendum on unification in
ireland i mean i would say two things on
that you know uh
symphony hasn't actually gained any
seats on this election it's the same
number of seats at last time it's that
they've done better than the dup because
the dup have had its votes split some of
it's gone to the tv which is more
hardline on the protocol and some of it
has gone to alliance which is the
cross community party
um but you know and also a referendum
isn't something that's going to be
automatically going to happen you know
and the good friday agreement for
referendum to take place there has to be
an indication that there would be
support for that and i'm not sure there
is that at the moment but i think people
in britain will be concerned about this
and thinking what is going to happen in
the future on the front page of the
observer they've got a quote from mary
lou mcdonald who is the president of
shin fang
she leads the party south of the border
and she says that unionists don't be
scared is her message the future is
bright for us all i think that her
saying don't be scared isn't going to
stop them being scared i think there
will be concerns in london that this
will possibly lead to a referendum that
could see the uk broken up
uh yeah it's the same uh photograph
exactly the same photograph actually on
the front of the sunday telegraph as
well of michelle o'neill and mary lou
mcdonald we could talk a lot more on
this but we've got so much to get
through and i want to talk about the uh
elections
in
england as well the front of the sunday
telegraph rachel housing crisis cost us
votes says gov the dust has obviously
settled uh now a little bit um and for
the tourists this was worse than just
the midterm blues
yeah i mean the conservatives really
took a hammering in these local
elections i'm not sure if it was about
housing although i can understand that
the housing minister would want to make
that the case but from what you know
what people were reporting
around that election and and um you know
what people were saying who are
canvassed it does seem that
uh partygate was a big big deal
particularly in um those seats uh in the
south the castle seats in the south
where you know the lib dems swept up
quite considerably in those areas
housing is an issue for sure and there's
a piece there's a stat in this piece
that is really glaring it says that in
20 24 to 30 something year olds so young
people
completely locked out of the housing
market the number of home owners in that
group has halved since the 80s and so
it's it's just impossible for
young people to attain the same standard
of living in any sense um economically
as their parents which is awful for a
generation to go backwards but i think
that's just one piece of of an economic
picture that is grim that is
you know
earning a wage is no longer enough to
guarantee freedom from anxiety over how
to put food over this on the table how
to pay essential bills and that's the
fundamental problem that you can have a
job and still be in poverty
that's
systemic yeah and that's something that
honestly neither of the major parties
has got a solution to right now yeah um
john just very briefly give me give me
your assessment of of how things went
for for the tories and labour and then
let's move on to the stama dinner party
also on the front of the telegraph
well the results were clearly
disappointing the tories there are lots
of places where the country around the
country where they've lost seats i think
the one good thing that they have found
is that on the other side
labour's support hasn't been growing
equally around the country so they did
quite well in scotland they did quite
well in wales and they obviously did
well in london but if you look at the
rest of england they didn't actually put
on that many council seats i think
that's why the tories aren't quite so
angry about the results as they could
have been
um and uh just staying with you uh john
stama dinner was planned there's this
new memo isn't there which is uh
bringing uh uh various things into
question yet again uh for the labour
leader
yeah this is a memo that's popped up in
the mail on sunday that this round just
keeps rumbling on and keeps creating
problems for kierstarma and what this
memo suggests it's actually a plan of
the day an agenda for kyostama for this
day in question which was april last
year and one of the things that kia
stammers said in the last few weeks is
that they just took a break from doing
bits of work to have this curry and have
this beer where he was pictured and then
they went back to work and what this
agenda for the day shows is that the
curry that he had was actually marked
down in the diary for the very end of
the day and then after that it just says
end of visit and i think this creates a
new problem for kia stammer he's not
also got the police investigating this
now but it's also questions about has he
actually been honest with the public
about this and when you speak to tory
mps who complain about how party gay
came up in the doors during the local
elections what they were saying is that
voters were more angry about that they
felt that boris johnson hadn't told the
truth about the parties rather than the
actual parties in the first place i
think there's a danger here that voters
will be crossed with kiss dharma if they
don't think that he's told the truth and
then added to that the hypocrisy of
complaining about stories having parties
if he is fined and found to have
breached the rules and i think that will
be a toxic combination of both
dishonesty and hypocrisy yeah rachel
you're nodding your head and you you
brought up party gate as well as as
being a big issue for for voters um i
mean sakira's sort of backed himself
into a bit of a corner here hasn't he
because he should never have said the
prime minister should resign because
there's a police investigation because
now he's in the position where there's a
police investigation and people are
saying well mate you need to go
yeah i mean it was strategically not the
smartest thing to do um but i think i
think that that appraisal is right um in
the sense that we're talking about
not so much annoyance with what actually
happened but annoyance at the lying at
the the dishonesty and the hypocrisy and
i think that's the trouble for
kierstarma now that it does look
profoundly hypocritical to have really
gone for uh boris johnson and then rishi
tsunak over partygay um and then be
found um you know being investigated
along similar lines now my worry and
actually you could see that reflected in
the fact that you know over the local
elections labor didn't actually make
that many gains parties that gained were
the dems
the greens independent candidates did
very well labor not so much now my
concern is not particularly with
kiestama or with boris johnson my
concern is that people are just going to
look at this lot and think what even is
the point they all lie they're all
dishonest they're all hypocritical so
we're just going to do so well
do you think that's why
well
sorry i'm saying do you think that's
part of the reason why the lib dems did
so well because it was almost uh
i don't want to vote for either of them
so i'll vote for you
i think that that's why the lib dems for
greens and independent candidates did so
well yeah
yeah okay let's move on because we're
running uh out of time just want to move
to sunday express uh john ever
optimistic uh pm promises brexit bill's
bonanza exclamation mark
yes this is the queen's speech which is
going to be taking place in on tuesday
when the government will set out its
legislative legislative agenda if i can
speak which will be its list of bills
that is planning to bring forward in the
next year or so and the sunday express
is reporting describes there's going to
be a super seven of brexit freedom bills
it says that there'll be
seven bits of legislation in there which
are linked to brexit using the kind of
freedoms that we've got since we left
the eu to do things although i've not
quite read the full article so i'm not
sure what exactly they are saying is
going to be in this legislation
a quick word on this rachel before we
move on
i'm just glad that i didn't have to say
that tongue twister but um i do think
this is really scraping the barrel there
there is no bonanza and actually in
legislative terms uh the conservatives
are looking pretty thin all round okay
i'm just staying with the rachel front
page of the sunday mirror now this is an
interesting one isn't it this is an
exclusive by sarah robertson i love the
headline just william it appears that
prince william and kate are set to be
addressed by name and not title in a
huge shake-up of of royal protocols so
instead of addressing them as the the
duke and duchess of cambridge it'll be
simply william and kate
rachel yeah i think that's great i think
that's a great headline as well
absolutely they're dropping formalities
they want to be referred to by first
names they're dropping formalities like
um
curtsies and bowels and all the rest of
it this is following their not so great
tour of the caribbean but i suspect that
the problem with i mean i'm not a
royalist so i suspect the problem with
the royal family
isn't the
formalities it's the concept itself that
people are rejecting
okay um and john
what do you think of this i mean it'd be
interesting wanted to see uh whether we
call kate kate or catherine because
william always calls her catherine
doesn't he where the rest of the country
seems to go with kate
yeah i think if you strip away all the
kind of formalities and the titles and
the curtsies and the bows then
i think people will question what
exactly do you have
left you know i think obviously if
william and kay or the duke and duchess
of cambridge are talking to children in
a hospital visit you can imagine them
wanting to be called william and kate i
think for normal engagements i think
it's quite normal that you call them the
duke and duchess of cambridge i think
that's all part of the royal family